-Look at it. It's real.
-It looks like a record.
-Exactly. Thanks for coming out.
You're performing the song
tonight.
-Yes, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
My backup dancers will be here
in just a second.
-Are you psyched about this?
I mean, look at this.
It's finally out.
-Yes, I've been working on this
for a really long time,
and now it's out in the world.
And I feel like --
I've felt like
I was 20 months pregnant
with this.
[ Laughter ]
For a very long time.
It's out in the world
and it's great.
And I want everybody
to know the story.
And also, I think it's terrible
and all I can think about is
what's wrong.
You know how it is.
You do something,
and all you can think is like,
"I want it to be perfect."
-But you were saying as you were
working on this, you went on
this crazy, awesome train --
kind of -- I guess
you can call it a vacation,
but you were working.
-Yeah, well --
-Well, you can't stop.
-This is an extended vacation
family plan that Susan and I had
with both of our families that
we had to put off twice
because of COVID.
And then finally,
we could all do it.
And it's mine and Susan's idea
of a fun time,
which is taking a train trip
that never ends.
-Yeah. I would think that would
be an amazing trip
for maybe like three days.
-No, we did it for 10.
-No.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-You can't leave the train?
-No. New York.
And then we went to Chicago.
And then we went to New Orleans.
Then we went to San Antonio
and Austin, all on the train.
It's fan-fricking-tastic.
-It is cool, right?
-But you have to like
"going places" and never
"getting anywhere," because you
never get off the --
You never get off the form of
transportation.
-All your photos are
just blurry trees.
-Yes, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
Also, like, "I fell down
in the hall again."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, exactly.
And my poor family, I was
working on this the whole time.
So, like, every time we go
across -- like, we see
a landmark
or we go across a bridge
that's named for a person,
I'm like, "I have YouTube clips
from 1937 from that person
giving a speech.
Everybody, gather around."
-Yeah and they're like,
"Stop working
Let's just have fun."
-"Let's play crazy eights,
Rachel. Stop and have a beer."
-Every Monday,
I know you're on MSNBC.
Everyone is talking about
midterm elections
and why they're important.
Can we just remind everyone why
midterm elections are important?
-So, I mean, every election
is important, right?
But this one is -- this one
feels like a very big deal.
It's the first election since
the sort of disastrous election
of 2020.
-Mm-hmm.
-And "The Washington Post" just
did a thing the other day where
they said -- they looked at all
the candidates running in
statewide races
and congressional races
all around the country.
And a numerical majority
of the Republican candidates
don't believe in
the last election results.
-Mm.
-So, that's hard because if you
don't believe elections are the
way we decide who is in power,
how exactly would you like us
to choose you?
[ Laughter ]
It's interesting. Yeah.
It's like, "Yeah, this is an
election, what you're doing."
-Yes. And so, if you don't think
that elections are how people
should get into power
in America,
I don't know what you want me
to do for you.
But I'm disinclined to vote
for you.
-Definitely some interesting
characters this time around.
-Yeah, there's -- I mean --
Political science
is not real science.
Like, it's not physics.
-Yeah.
-But to the extent that there is
a political science rule
in America, it is after --
if your party currently has
a president in the White House,
the next time
there's an election,
you're going to get shellacked.
Like, that's basically the rule.
-It's usually what happens.
Yeah.
-It's almost always what
happens.
So because we've got a Democrat,
Joe Biden, in the White House,
that means, in political science
terms, the Democrats
should expect to not do well
in these elections.
But Herschel Walker, you know?
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, it's just every day you
go, "Oh, my goodness."
-Yeah. And, I mean, really,
they -- like, the nominee for
governor in Arizona doesn't
believe in election results.
-Yeah.
-Like, what then?
I would do a lot of things
with you,
but not participate in
an election.
-Yeah, interesting.
-That's the thing.
That's not a thing for you.
-Do you think Trump started
a whole new type of world
with these candidates?
-Trump saying that he didn't
lose the last election and still
should be in power and there
should be some other way
to reinstall him in power is a
thing now in Republican politics
and it's not a fringe thing.
It's a majority of
their candidates.
And so, that's, in part, why
this whole election
is really important
because if one of the two major
parties is going to go
that direction where elections
aren't how we determine
the future of political power,
well, there isn't really
another good choice.
-Yeah.
-So it makes this important.
There's also a bunch of other --
you know, there's another --
a lot of really practical things
that matter in the --
for this election and the world.
You know, the Democrats and
Biden have been very supportive
of Ukraine with Russia
waging war on Ukraine.
It's not at all clear
the Republicans
would continue doing that.
With Roe vs. Wade being
overturned, the more power
Republicans have, the more bans
on abortion we're going to have.
And the Republicans in Congress,
if they get power, they want
a national abortion ban.
That means every state.
That includes New York.
That includes California.
That includes everywhere.
So it's just -- this is not
the election to sit out.
-Yeah.
-It's four weeks from tomorrow.
Whatever your political
preferences are, this is
going to be a really,
really consequential one.
-Yeah, we'll be watching you.
Can we talk about "Ultra"?
-Yeah.
-How did you find this story?
Tell everyone what it's about.
It's very, very interesting.
-Okay, so you know
we had January 6th.
That was bad.
-Yes.
-We've had other problems like
that before, and I feel like
there's something that's
happened over the past like
seven or eight years
where every time something new
and terrible happens in
the news, we're like,
"This is unprecedented.
This has never happened before."
And that's true
until you look it up.
[ Laughter ]
There's always some --
-Someone's done it already.
-Some terrible precedent.
And so, there's this amazing
case in 1944, where like
30 people --
more than two dozen people
all got put on trial
for sedition,
for trying to violently
overthrow the government.
And okay, we just had
an experience like that.
We've got people on trial
for sedition now. Okay.
And when it happened in 1944,
in the middle of the trial,
the judge died
and they all got off.
-Is that right?
-Yes.
And it turns out that there was
all these members of Congress
who really were on the side of
the accused seditionists,
and they leaned on
the Justice Department.
They told the attorney general
he needed to fire
the main prosecutor, and he did.
Like, that can't be.
You can't do that.
That's crazy town.
Turns out there were all these
members of Congress who were,
like, taking money
from the Hitler government,
from the actual Nazis.
Not the metaphorical Nazis.
The N-N-Nazis. The real Nazis.
[ Laughter ]
And they were going to get
in trouble for it.
And then they were like, "No,
shut down the investigation."
And it did get shut down.
It's bananas.
-How do you find all this stuff
and how do you know about this?
Deep dive.
-I live in a dark place.
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
You go in there and you find
these amazing stories.
And how many podcasts are there
for the whole series?
-It's an eight-episode series.
And we just dropped
the first two episodes today.
It's free. You can get it
anywhere you get your podcasts.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Like, I've been dying to tell
this story.
And so, it's finally getting
out there.
And I'm making myself
absolutely crazy about it.
But I hope people
dig it as much.
-It's out. Congratulations.
"Ultra," everybody.
Check it out wherever you listen
to your podcasts.
"Rachel Maddow Show," Mondays
at 9:00 p.m. on MSNBC.
Thank you so much.
Always good to see you.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show." Come on back.